some forms were dated a few hours late  they want  every result from all of those  ballot boxes thrown out and not counted  they want to disenfranchise tens of  thousands of voters  because of some messed up paperwork with  some of these ballots now the law that  they cite is this emergency declaration  which has rules for ballot drop boxes  it doesn't say  if any rule is  violated you throw the all the ballots  in the box into the trash it doesn't  actually say that it doesn't say throw  the votes out and don't count them so  all of this is being signal boosted by  articles being written that say  because it appears that maybe some  ballots had a uh  were a few hours late in being certified  you need to just throw out all the  ballots from those ballot boxes there's  nothing in the law that suggests that  that should be happening